H
THE EXPECTED MIGRANT SEARCH WHEN
THE IMMIGRATION RESTRICTIONS ARE
SCHEDULED TO END NEXT MONTH.
TO DISCUSS LATEST DEVELOPMENTS,
TEXAS CONGRESSMAN CHIP ROY.
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHRIS MURPHY
OUT OF CONNECTICUT SAID THIS, HE
TWEETED "REPUBLICAN LEADERS
DON'T SEE IMMIGRANTS AS HUMAN,
JUST PROPS TO GET SOME LAUGHS
AND CLICKS."
HE SAID ABOUT THIS BUS THAT
ARRIVED IN WASHINGTON, HOW DO
YOU RESPOND?
>> THAT'S RICH COMING FROM
DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE BEEN USING
IMMIGRANTS AS PROPS FOR THEIR
OWN POLITICAL PURPOSES WHILE
MIGRANTS GET ABUSED AND PUT INTO
SEX TRAFFICKING AND CARTELS GET
EMPOWERED, TEXANS GET RUN OVER.
THAT'S THE WHOLE SHTICK, USE
DEMOCRATS DON'T MAKE MIGRANTS AS
PROPS, NOW YOU HAVE
GOVERNOR ABBOTT BRING ATTENTION
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN TEXAS
WHILE DEMOCRATS LIKE
SENATOR MURPHY INTO THE
DEMOCRATS IGNORE IT.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IS TRYING TO DO
THE JOB THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE SECRETARY
IS SUPPOSED TO BE DOING.
I'M GLAD THE GOVERNOR IS
BRINGING ATTENTION TO IT, I'M
GLAD THE GOVERNOR IS BRINGING
ATTENTION TO WHAT WE HAVE TO DO
BY HAVING VEHICLE EXPECTION AND
CAUSING PEOPLE TO HAVE TO WAKE
UP AT WHAT HAPPENS AT OUR
BORDER.
LET'S BE CLEAR, TOMORROW THERE'S
STILL GOING TO BE 7,000 ARE A
THOUSAND PEOPLE COMING ACROSS
OUR BORDER.
THE ONLY METRIC I'M GOING TO BE
GRADING ANYBODY ON HOW THIS
REPORTS OUT IS WHETHER OR NOT WE
STOP THE FLOW OF TRAFFIC AT THE
BORDER AND SECURE OUR BORDER
PROTECTIONS FOR AMERICANS SO WE
AREN'T HAVING MET AN OLD POOR
INDOOR SCHOOLS AND HAVING PEOPLE
GET ABUSED OR HEARD WHETHER THEY
ARE MIGRANTS OR AMERICANS.
>> Shannon: NOT SURPRISING
THERE WOULD BE CRITICISM FROM
THE LEFT WITH ARGUABLY ON THE
RIGHT.
APIECE IN "THE FEDERALIST" CALLS
GOVERNOR ABBOTT OUT -- HE CAN
SECURE THE BORDER, HE CAN SHUT
IT DOWN.
ABBOTTS BUSING ORDER IS QUITE
OBVIOUSLY A STUNT, CHEAP SHOT AT
BY THEN THAT NO EFFECTIVE USE OF
HIS CONSIDERABLE POWER AS
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS.
IF YOU WERE SERIOUS HE WOULDN'T
ANNOUNCE A PLAN TO TRANSFER THEM
TO WASHINGTON BUT A PLAN TO TAKE
THEM BACK TO MEXICO, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE CRITICISM?
>> I WANT TO REPEAT, THE PROBLEM
RIGHT NOW AT OUR BORDER LIES
SQUARELY AT THE FEET OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND SECRETARY
MAYORKAS.
AMERICANS ARE GETTING HURT,
MIGRANTS ARE GETTING HURT COME
OUR ECONOMY IS GETTING HURT.
I APPLAUD WITH THE GOVERNOR HAS
BEEN DOING, HE'S BEEN TRYING TO
PUT THE SPOTLIGHT ON THIS.
THIS AT THE FEET OF THE FOLKS IN
WASHINGTON BUT I DO AGREE THAT
ULTIMATELY WE CAN'T ALLOW THIS
TO CONTINUE.
RECOGNIZE THIS IS HIS AND
INVASION IN TEXAS IS GOING TO
NEED TO GO DOWN TO THE BORDER
AND START TURNING PEOPLE AWAY.
PRESENT THE UNITED STATES
REFUSES TO DO HIS JOB.
I KNOW THERE'S A SOME OF THESE
DEMOCRATS THAT WANT TO JUMP
ABOARD, LET'S BE CLEAR.
WE HAVE AN EFFORT ON THE FLOOR
OF THE HOUSE, THAT WOULD
DISCHARGE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
USE TITLE 42 A METS RECOGNIZED
TITLE 42 THAT WOULD HELP UNDER
THE PANDEMIC, THAT'S A BAND-AID
ON A GUNSHOT WOUND.
WE NEED TO STAND UP AND SECURE
THE BORDER AND ACTUALLY TURN
PEOPLE AWAY INSTEAD OF ALLOWING
OUR COUNTRY TO GET INTO THIS.
I THOUGHT THE GOVERNOR FOR
TRYING TO FIGURE SPOTLIGHT ON IT
BUT I AGREE THAT TEXAS IS GOING
TO HAVE TO DO MORE.
>> EVERY FEW DAYS, FROM ONE
TODAY SENATOR SAID THIS.
DISCUSSED THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PLANS TO LIFT THE TITLE 42 42 OR
AND MUCH-NEEDED STAFFING AWAY
FROM THEIR DAILY
RESPONSIBILITIES, PROTECTING
TRADE AND PREVENTING THE FLOW OF
FENTANYL AND OTHER ILLICIT DRUGS
AND FIREARMS.
THAT WASN'T FROM A REPUBLICAN,
IT CAME FROM DEMOCRATS, ARIZONA
SENATOR MARK KELLY.
IS THERE ENOUGH BIPARTISAN WILL
TO DO SOMETHING AND HOW BAD DO
YOU THINK REALISTICALLY THINGS
WILL GET WHEN TITLE 42 LIFTS
NEXT MONTH.
>> LET'S KEEP IN MIND LAST YEAR
WE HAD 7,000 PEOPLE RELEASED
INTO THE UNITED STATES FOR
2 MILLION APPREHENSIONS.
THE REST OF THOSE FOLKS WERE
TURNED AWAY UNDER TITLE 42.
WHAT EVERY AMERICAN NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND IS TITLE 42 IS A
HEALTH CODE PROVISION, THERE ARE
ALL THESE OTHER POLICIES OF THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION IS
IGNORING.
THEY ARE ALLOWING THE ASYLUM
RULES TO SWALLOW OUR BORDER
SECURITY, ALLOWING ASYLUM TO BE
THE EXCEPTION THAT SWALLOWS THE
RULE.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW THIS BECAUSE YOU'VE
BEEN FOLLOWING IT AND WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT REAL PROBLEMS.
FENTANYL, AMERICANS DYING, RANCH
IS GETTING OVERRUN, CARTELS IN
POWER.
THERE IS A REFUSAL TO RECOGNIZE
WHAT IT IS DOING TO TEXAS AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
DEMOCRATS RECOGNIZE IT BECAUSE
POLITICALLY THEY ARE GETTING
CRUSHED.
HISPANICS IN TEXAS, YOU SAW THE
POLLS TODAY.
HISPANICS ARE NOT LINING UP
BEHIND JOE BIDEN, THEY HAVE BEEN
TAKEN FOR GRANTED FOR A LONG
TIME.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING ARE DEMOCRATS
RECOGNIZING THEY HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
ONE LAST POINT.
JUST BECAUSE THERE IS A RUSH TO
DO A BIPARTISAN BILL, I DON'T
WANT TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
PLANNING.
I DON'T WANT ANY MORE WORDS.
I GOT REPUBLICANS LINING UP
BEHIND A MICROPHONE AND SAYING A
BIPARTISAN BILL SO THEY WILL
PRESENT A PLAN AND TO SAY NOW
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY IS
OVER, SO NOW WE WILL SAY TITLE
42 CAN BE DISPENSED WITH.
NOW, LET'S ACTUALLY MAKE SURE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
GOTTEN RID OF THE EMERGENCY,
STATES AREN'T UNDER AN EMERGENCY
AND WE HAVE A REGULAR FLOW OF
TRAFFIC BETWEEN MEXICO AND
CANADA.
WE HAVE TO DISCHARGE PETITION ON
THE FLOOR.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ANY MORE
WORDS.
FINALLY I WANT TEXAS AND ARIZONA
TO STAND UP AND SECURE OUR
BORDER USING ARTICLE FOUR UNDER
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> Shannon: THERE ARE REAL
HUMAN BEINGS COTTON IS TAKEN
TAKEN IT A TRAFFICKING AND HELD
IN HOSTAGE, MANY OF THEM DIE ON
THESE JOURNEYS TOO THAT WE HAVE